hello and welcome to part two of our
image recognition and image manipulation
tutorial series where we left off with
our visit is downloading everything that
we needed and now we're ready to start
programming if you don't know how to get
to this window so if this is really your
introduction to even Python once you've
downloaded and installed Python if you
go to your Start bar and search for I D
as in dog l II you should find idle and
then in parenthesis Python GUI or GUI
click on that and I should bring up this
window here and you could program in
here but I don't prefer it so you can go
file new window and that'll bring up an
empty window and then you can
subsequently close out of this window
then you should have something called
like untitled right so it's like an
untitled text document you can type
stuff in here and it's cool subsequently
the next thing you'll want to do is you
want to file save as and you'll save it
in the same directory I'm going to close
out of this because I don't need this
but you'll save it in the same directory
as that image folder so if I was to save
this one which is what we'll be coding
in it brings up in here and so I've got
the image file folder here that you
could extract from tutorial images so if
you double-click this what's in here is
that numbers file and all that I'll go
back make sure you save this video like
the program that we're going to be
typing in save that file right here in
the same directory as images and when
you do save the file make sure at the
end of the file you put diet' py
otherwise it just saves it as a regular
file and it's kind of annoying so anyway
once you've done that you should be here
at this empty screen and you're ready to
go so the first thing that we need to do
is bring in all the other imports that
we are going to be working with so
basically the stuff that we downloaded
if you didn't already have it so like I
said in the previous video if you're
operating on a 32-bit version of Python
then you will impute this you will
import capital I am a GE now I'm on
64-bit and I'm not using pil so we're
just going to leave that out but it
just comment this if you are on 32-bit
OS then you will do that otherwise if
you're going to be working with us with
the same things that we've used you're
going to do from PIL which actually is
from pillow not Python imaging library
it import capital I ma GE so besides
this change right here in in the first
line of our script nothing else will be
different from what we code so no matter
what you're using you should be able to
follow along no problem so next thing we
want us to import numpy so we're going
to do import numpy as NP now that way
when we call numpy we can just type NP
as a full non PI because we're lazy now
let's talk about how to work with an
image so if we bring up in our directory
you can double click on images and that
should look like this so what I'd like
to do is let's just open up a simple
very simple image and we'll open up this
dot image so let me just bring that up
it is you probably can't even see it in
the video but it's a really another
minute it's just a dot in the corner
alright so that's the image that we're
going to look at real quick just for
basic reasons so we'll say I for
shorthand image equals capital I ma GE
dot open and then you're going to want
to specify the path to that image so if
you put this script in the same
directory as that images folder all you
have to do is images slash dot PNG but
if you put it somewhere else you'll need
to give the full path or you can do like
some tricks with this stuff but if you
if you're not comfortable you should
just make sure the script is in the same
directory and if it says it can't find
it then either you've made a typo or
just try to give the exact full file
path next we're going to say I a are and
what IA are is standing for is just
we're just making it up it's a variable
but I a are in my mind is image right
for the eye and then AR will be the
array and then that's going to equal NP
as array and then what do we want to
convert to an array or a numpy array
rather we're going to use eye
right so what this is going to do is
going to spit out an array that
corresponds to our image and the image
array is going to come out as a three
dimensional or three dimensional array
so this means there's an array within an
array within term array or if you use a
list it would be a list within a list
within a list depending on how we're
reading it in Python that's what it's
going it's going to be different things
right and then entire list you know so
the out side dimension is the whole
image the second dimension in is going
to correspond to each row and the third
dimension in in corresponds to each
pixel in that row and the items within
that list of the pixel is your red green
blue or RGB and then you've got alpha
and that's for each pixel so let's go
ahead and look at an example since that
might sound really confusing so we're
going to print out iar and just print it
to the console now you'll just need to
make sure you go file save or you can do
ctrl s and then to run the script you
either hit run and then run module or
you can hit f5 so that should bring it
up and it will print out this array here
so as we can see we've gone let me see
yeah I can't really scroll this out but
on yours you should see you know like a
box of numbers all right and then
another box and another box and all the
boxes pretty much should be 255 within
them except for the first one it's got a
zero zero zero and at 255 so this entire
array right that is let me just fit
everything into this window that is the
image right now each one of these arrays
here actually let me get it right like
this each one of these and actually it's
not this anyway each one of these right
is the row within the image and our
image is an 8 by 8 so let me go ahead
and bring that image back up again let's
edit it so it comes up in paint and I'll
just drag it over zoom in so as you can
see you know there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 by
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 I'll take my where
for it or you can look at it but anyway
yeah if we want to resize right 8x8
anyway so that's our image and so we
have eight of these rows 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 &
8 and then also within that row we've
got our pixels and like this is a pixel
in that row this is another pixel and we
census in 8x8 we're going to have 8
pixels right so you can almost use like
the pixel is like part of the column and
then this entire list of pixels is a row
so anyway that's just some basics we'll
get into more detail in the next video
if you're having any trouble up to this
point feel free to use the comment box
most of the comments go to my email and
I do respond to the comments so if
you're having any problems just feel
free to post your question or your
problem and I'll do my best to help you
out anyway as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support and subscriptions
and until next time